all right hello and welcome back to yet
another analysis
so this time magnus carlsen against
ikaro nakamura from the 11th
round and the skilling open this is the
last day
this is when it will be decided who
advances and who
is eliminated so let's take a look at
this game
e45 magnus went for bishop c4
known as the bishop's opening i'm not
gonna replay knight of six
attacking the pawn on e4 d3 from
from magnus and here he nakamura is
invited to play bishop c5 which will
transpose into
an italian game for example knight f3
knight c6 but he went for c6 which is
the other main move here the point is
that
he wants to play play d5 quickly take
control over the center and this is
another huge line with a lot of theory
and of course the players are aware of
that and they play
quite quickly here knight f3 d5
should be three i can mention that you
do not really want to take because then
black gets
his uh his center and after bishop b5
check black can simply play bishop d7
and white is forced to take and then and
then black takes back
with protection of the e5 pawn with an
excellent position
so e takes d5 is not really possible
here bishop b3
is the main move bishop before check
bishop d2 bishop takes
knight takes queen c7 protecting the
pawn on e5
castles d takes e4
and um i i suppose black could also
simply play
play castle here this is uh another type
of position
rookie one is uh very logical
threatening to take on d5 and then later
on e5
and then this can be defended with an
ipd7 and we have a fairly
fairly equal position at our hands here
with chances for both sides
but nakamura went for dtak c4
magnus uh played at knight g5 which is a
good movie one
he wants to take back with the knight
while he's also
attacking an opponent of seven uh
castles protects the opponent of seven
you may wonder if bishop g4 here is
possible this is always in the air when
this happens and um it definitely is
it looks like a very interesting move to
me
maybe simply queen e1 and then we would
get something similar to the game after
castles and knight takes e4
so castles knight takes c4
knight d5 akamura does not want to take
back
i'm not really sure why but
this is slightly more pleasant for white
and you could then say that
white is slightly slightly better
so 95 is another attempt to
maybe play h6 chase away the knight on
g5
put the knight on f4 eventually also
when he plays h6 he's then free to play
bishop e6
and then he is quite okay and that's why
magnus already strikes in the center
here with the d4 which i think
is an excellent move h6 knight f3
bishop g4 pinning in knight on f3
i guess it's also possible to take here
on d4 where i'll gladly take with
with the queen uh we have massive
control here over the center and um
we are definitely better here
because after we should be six we can
always play knight c5 and this is
extremely unpleasant
and clearly worse for for black
so bishop g4 instead t takes c5
knight d7 black will take back on f3 and
on e5
any second but magnus plays h3
bishop takes queen takes queen takes c5
and then magnus plays rookie one he's
now looking at some
discoveries against the queen here
rook get a e8 some more or less
protecting against every single
discovery because something like knight
c5 is always going to be met by queen
takes e1
where black will be winning c3
protecting the pawn on b2 while also
taking the important d4 square
knight f6 and here magnus makes a very
interesting exchange sacrifice
or a blunder one of the two i honestly
think it was
uh was a blunder the tactic that
nakamura
plays is absolutely brilliant and i do
not think magnus thought he had enough
for
for the exchange i do think though that
black
is now comfortably equalized here so
for example after knight takes f6 queen
takes f6 this is
definitely likely to end up in
a in a draw so maybe i wanted to
complicate things a little bit with the
rook 81 but unfortunately it doesn't
quite
work so let's take a look
so was it a blunder was it an an
exchange
sacrifice who knows
but nakamura played and i take c4
rook takes d7 and here the brilliancy
the only reason why this works knight g5
and this is an excellent move
so i'm sure magnus saw this so he played
queen e3
and he might have thought like
well this is very good for me because if
black
is forced to move the queen away we can
simply play queen d2
and this queen this rook here on d7 is
extremely strong with massive pressure
on f7 and b7
so that doesn't quite work out for black
and same thing happens if we take
we'll simply take back and again we're
attacking these
uh these pawns and black is uh is lost
but unfortunately for magnus nakamura
has this brilliant move
knight f3 check and the point here
is that if we take back with uh with the
if you take with the queen
queen takes e1 is coming so we're forced
to take with
with the pawn but the problem is then
when we take with the pawn
queen g5 is coming with an excellent
excellent
discovery here on the queen and thus
magnus is forced to take the queen and
here
nakamura takes the rook with check so
it's a very nice combination
for a move combination right there and
this gives nakamura
an advantage with an exchange an
exchange up
uh an important factor is that magnus
king
magnus's king here is extremely weak
this can be exploited if if nakamura
gets both of his rooks
down the first rank here which is
essentially the winning plan but it's
easier said and done
so nakamura played a5 protecting the
pawn on a7
a4 from uh from magnus
g6 by nakamura wants to give this king
some air
bishop c4 prevents rookie two also b3
is possible in a few lines king g7
rook c7 and here nakamura missus says
his big chance to to take a huge step
towards
towards victory and it's certainly a
hard move to find
but we did talk about this idea earlier
on
doubling the rooks on the first rank
so rook c1 here would be an excellent
excellent move
point is that we want to play rook d8
followed by rook t1
at some point but the problem is that
that magnus is attacking the pawn and f7
so that can't really be done yet
but rook c1 is a great waiting move
because we're also threatening to play
rook c2 followed by rook takes b2
so for example the line could go rook
takes c6
and here i like to move rook b8
attacking the pawn on b2 b3
and a very important move f5
there is no longer possible to play rook
c7 and attack the pawn on f7
and this is going to be quite decisive
f4 is also possible later
and you can see that the white's king is
extremely extremely weak
so for example rook a6
i would think that rook d8 here is more
or less
winning for for white very close
at least with f4 and rook team one
coming and the mate
is very hard to avoid
so rook c1 would have been a very good
move
what happens in the game is that
nakamura plays a rookie five
and then magnus takes on c6 rook v8
put you again you see the problem he
plays rook c7
and he attacks on f7 so magnus
uh no nakamura sorry it plays rook takes
b2
magnus takes on f7 with the bishop and
here magnus has enough compensation it's
quite difficult
for nakamura to get anything going here
with rook b1 and rook e1
is simply too slow so he's he tries to
g1
but then magnus plays bishop c4 check
king h8
and a perpetual arises after rook c8
king just king ju7 rook c7 king h8
rook c8 and uh for the draw
uh king h6 here would have been would
have been a huge mistake
after bishop g8 and after g4 h4
black is the one that's mated not white
which is quite
hilarious the line could go takes takes
g5
and then rook h7 king g6
h5 king f6 rook f7
king e5 and rook e7 if they were hanging
on e1
interesting in turn of events of course
nakamura is never going to fall for that
if he was going to play rook
if he was going to play king f7 king f6
he would lose after rook f7 check and
rookie 7
and if he was going to play
king f8 rook f7 here is
a draw as well for example king e8
and then rook g7 and magnus will take
both of these pawns
at least upon a g6 and it's
going to end in a draw for example rick
b1
only move to avoid mate is f4 but this
is enough for
for a draw a very interesting game that
ended in
[Music]
in a draw between magnus and nakamura
who are both on their way to qualify to
the knockout stage and
skilling open